can you also maybe define rationalism
yeah these are two terms that are in
philosophy especially in epistemology
they're often
uh compared to one another your own said
that it's an uh that it's a false
dichotomy and and and maybe it is a bit
exaggerated but that doesn't mean it's
not useful for for conceptualizing the
the domain so
rationalist is somebody like descartes
who says um
i'm going to set aside i'm going to try
to set aside everything i know
everything i've inherited i'm going to
start from scratch and he explicitly
says you know
in evaluating the the inheritance of the
past he explicitly says
you take a look at the histories that we
have they're not reliable you take a
look at the moral and the scientific
writings that we receive they're not
very good his baseline is to look
very critically at the past and say
look i'm evaluating it i i think all in
all it's just not worth very much and so
whatever i do
going
beginning from scratch is going to be
better as long as and he here's his
caveat this is as long as i'm proceeding
from
uh from self-evident
uh assumptions from self-evident
premises things that you can't argue
against i think therefore i am right and
then from there deducing what what he
calls infallible conclusions so that
model of self-evident premises to
infallible conclusions
i'm i'm calling that rationalism i think
that's kind of a kind of a standard you
know academic
uh jargon term and it's opposed to uh
empiricism which is a thinker i i think
in universities usually the you know the
empiricist is uh is david yum
and uh david yum uh will say
we can't learn anything the way that
descartes i mean there is nothing that's
that self-evident and that infallible so
so
hume proposes
based on uh
newton and and boyle and you know the
the the
the the new physical sciences so um
proposes
a science of man and the science of man
sounds an awful lot like what euron just
said which is we're going to take a look
at human nature at the nature of
societies
human nature we're going to try to
abstract towards
fixed principles for describing it human
societies we're going to try to do the
same thing
and from there we get you know for for
ex for example contemporary economics
but we also get you know sociology and
anthropology which which cut in in a
different different direction so
that's rationalism versus empiricism
you